Bonjour ! Croyez vous au "Paranormal" ?
Aux esprits vengeurs, aux fantômes ?
*rire*
J'ai hésité à appeler cette vidéo "Essayez de ne pas avoir peur"
Puis je me suis souvenu que mon public était composé de froussards qui n'auraient pas cliqué par peur de faire une crise cardiaque.
Les amis aujourd'hui c'est un énorme kiff qu'on va faire. On va regarder ensemble des vraies vidéos
Qui prennent en flagrant délit des apparitions... paranormales
Voici la vidéo "Real Ghost Caught On Tape Montage" qui a donc 10 000 j'aime pas.
On pars donc sur des vidéos "Fake" à mon avis, mais bon
On va regarder ça et décrypter, voir si c'est du "Fake" , ou pas ensemble.
Mec, j'ai passer des dizaines de soirées à faire ça tout seul jusqu’à 3 heures du matin
Je faisait pas l'amour à l'époque hein ?
Ah ça je peux te le dire !
C'est parti.
*Cris puis question incompréhensible*
*Arrêt soudain de la vidéo*
*rire*
Ah elle est drôle ! T'as vu je regarde quand même si la meuf est pas là, d'un coup, on sait pas, on sait jamais.
ça c'est la technique la plus facile pour faire croire à une apparition de fantôme:
C'est demander à ta petite fille asiatique de 6 ans qui a les cheveux plus noirs que... que la mousse de ce micro
De se mettre à la porte, puis de courir en haut des marches.
La meuf court puis elle refait la scène avec sa fille cette fois qui est en haut des marches
Elle repart du même endroit et on fait un raccord image.
J'suis désolé de briser vos rêves mais je suis une énorme merde aux fléchettes, bien que j'aime ça.
Et c'est le trucage qu'on a utilisé dans cette vidéo-là avec Clément
Si tu regardes image par image, tu arrives à peu près à voir deux images qui normalement ne se suivent pas
C'est un raccord.
BREF! Cette première vidéo était à chier.
Deuxième vidéo!
*Musique de film d'horreur*
*Ombre qui passe derrière*
Alors ! Cet effet ! Donc là il y quelqu'un, on le voit, bien évidemment, il est énorme.
Bref, il est là, il avance et il y a une sorte de traînée derrière...
Traînée qui s'apparente finalement à un effet de duplication sur Windows Movie Maker !
L'effet est très simple sauf qu'il est de très loin donc on croit forcément que c'est un fantôme qui fait un truc bizarre!
Bonjour je suis hantéééé...
C'est exactement ce qui se passe avec cette personne dans cette vidéo!
Pourtant j'suis très froussard hein.
J'y crois à mort à ce genre de trucs.
Mais là... Il faut pas se foutre de la gueule ...
euh... de Lulu Auchard.
Suivant!
Oh non, ça j'aime pas.
Oh j'aime pas du tout!
*Sifflements du vent*
Attends... *rires*
Depuis quand y'a un vent comme ça dans une maison, non mais... les gars...
Si vous voulez être crédibles, arrêtez aussi...
Ah!
ça bouge!
Ah c'est lui! Qu'on voit d'une autre caméra.
Bon c'est très bien fait, c'est très bien fait, c'est juste une ombre, ça peut être fait aussi sur photoshop.
Ah par contre, la bonne nouvelle c'est que j'ai trouvé la source du bruit.
Ce ventilateur d'usine. Voilà.
Ah non mais on élucide des mystères!
Ok ! Attention, vidéo suivante !
*BRUIT*
*Petite fille transparente qui passe*
*Rires*
Oh le gars, il s'est pas fait chier quoi
Il a juste détourer sa fille, il a ajouté un p'tit effet de transparence
C'est un fantôme ça passe
T’inquiète j'ai fait les FX de Insidius
et de "Conjuring : Les dossiers de Waren"
ils y verront que du feu
ha c'est les z'... les  *air choqué étonné*
j'suis offusqué... un solide bleu
qui arrive et qui atterrit et qui a une forme humaine
alors attention la j'm'engage a faire un montage aussi fort que celui ci par mes propres moyens
c'est parti
talentueux ou pas
bon j'me suis pas trop cassé le cul a ternir l'image et a la rendre encore plus degueulasse qu'elle ne l'est
comme la technique du mec dans la video bien evidement
J'ai pris le solide bleu
J'lai détouré, j'avais la flemme de le faire changer de forme en mouvement parce que ça casse les couilles, ça m'aurait pris du temps là...
C'est extraordinaire, c'était l'intervention de Squeezie
Suivant !
Ca va être bien pourri ça!
Ca va être bien bien pourri!
*Bruit terrifiante*
Voilà, quand Papa ne sait plus comment faire plaisir à sa fille
"Eh ma fille! On va faire genre ton reflet, c'est un fantôme!"
"T'es le meilleur papa du monde!"
"Je sais! Et encore, t'as pas vu mon skill sur Photoshop!"
Voilà! J'avais pas de fin de... *rire*
Ah là! Là ça à l'air sérieux là!
Qu'est-ce que c'est?
*Musique "angoissante"*
*Rire*
Oh c'est hilarant!
Mais de toutes les vidéos que j'ai regardé comme ça de ma vie, c'est la plus hilarante!
Oh j'vous l'fait! J'suis obligé de vous la faire celle-là!
C'est parti!
*Même musique qui fait pas peur*
Je sais ce que vous pensez...
C'était fidèle à l'original!
Nan franchement mais c'est le plus honteux quoi
J'le revois parce que c'est incroyable!
C'est incroyable comme c'est honteux ce montage de MERDE!
Ca dégage, faites-nous vibrer!
Ah celui-là j'crois que j'l'ai déjà vu, il est hyper badant!
On dirait qu'il y a quelqu'un à la fenêtre
Mais vous voyez, comme par hasard! C'est toujours...
*Rire*
J'sais pas si c'est du fake, mon gars!
Mais starfoullah!
Ca fait un peu peur!
J'me dis, pourquoi les fantômes ils sont toujours filmés par un potatoe?
Nan mais c'est vrai!
C'est jamais un bon Sony Alpha 7S qui va filmer ça!
Ou une Red! Sur un tournage de film à la Red, y a jamais un fantôme qui va passer!
Ce sera toujours filmé avec un... Avec un sablier mon gars!
Ouais j'arrête pas de le caler, il est là, il faut qu'il serve à quelque chose!
Suivant!
** Musique terrifiante **
Encore une ombre!
Ah non!
Juste un mec qui joue avec sa housse de couette blanche!
Mais non mais les gars...
C'est un concours du mec qui fait le truc le plus hilarant là, ou...
No comment! No comment!
Non mais mieux vaut pour lui qu'on commente pas!
What the fuck?
Attends mais, déjà, c'est le décor d'un film d'horreur!
Le jouet qui se balance tout seul
PLUS LA CHAISE! DE LA GRAND-MERE DECEDEE SUR CETTE MÊME CHAISE, DEUX JOURS AVANT!
A minuit! Après avoir dit 3 fois "Dame blanche"!
Si le truc qui fait peur c'est juste la chaise qui bouge toute seule...
** Screaming**
AAAAH!
Il m'a fait peur le con!
Allez on continue, on continue, c'est trop incroyable!
"Cette vidéo contient des flash, des lights, des bruits, des jumpscares"
Parfait! Y a tout pour qu'on crève!
Oh ça c'est horriiiible!
Ah c'est hardcore les explorations pour ça, mec!
C'est tellement le scénario que tu n'as pas envie qu'il se passe!
La chaîne elle a bougé toute seule
après, mec, j'avoue ça peut être l'un de...
Ca peut être un gros coup de vent, un énorme coup de vent
Un cyclone qui passe à quelques centimètres du mec, du coup il le sent pas
Ooooh...
Ah c'est horrible, en plus dans les mines et tout, y a eu tellement des morts...
Un lieu hanté, souvent, c'est lié au fait qu'il y ait eu, euuuh....
Beaucoup de morts ( captain obvious XD )
Du coup on dit qu'il est hanté, finalement, c'est en fait un peu notre peur de la mort
C'est beau c'que j'dis!
Là le mec dit que la température ambiante a chuté autour de lui
Et ça c'est horrible, c'est pas
Tu peux pas savoir ce qui s'passait parce que le mec il est en transe
Parce qu'il vient de voir une chaine bougée toute seule
Donc il en peut plus de sa vie
En mode : AAAAAAAHHHH
Et du coup il a froid etc.
Ou alors si c'est vraiment un petit gobelin comme ça
Un fantôme gobelin
Moi j'adore les gobelins
Il a poussé la chaise comme ça : NYYYYAAAAAHH !!
Tu as froid maintenant
J'sais pas *rires*
ok vidéo suivante, c'est un mec qui travaille dans euh, un truc qui vend des DVD ou des livres
j'sais pas trop
Et apparemment un objet va bouger tout seul
Oh..
Oooooh...
*rires* Le mec il est choqué
*Là c'est Squeezie qui est choqué XD*
Oh c'est très badant, très très badant
Mais après ça aurait pu tombé tout seul tu me diras
C'est ce que... se ce que... ( qu'est ce que tu veux nous dire squeezie XD !!! )
Non mais attend....
Mais là mec mais change d'emploi, quitte, va chez Monoprix
Va chez Monoprix tout de suite
Non pas une troisième fois, si c'est une troisième fois c'est abusé
Mais le mec il reste serein c'est abusé
Moi j'serais parti en courant, mon gars
Je serais allé choper la bande de la caméra de suveillance
Comme ça, pour faire mon petit buzz
Et je serais parti, par exemple, en criant : ABONNEZ-VOUS !!!!
Mec c'est chaud !!
*Anglais*
Mais what the fuck
Ca c'est un cas typique qu'on voit le mec il zoom x20
Et du coup tu vois plus que des pixels
J'vous ai dis putain mais filmer en HD
Pourquoi les gens qui filment en HD bizarrement y'a jamais d'apparitions
C'est ça, ça m'énerve
*Bruit*
Oh putain ! Oh c'est pas le moment ! Starfoulah
Alors c'est une fille assise sur sa chaise
Toute seule
*bruit bizarre*
Ooooh...
Ca a pas rebougé. Il va pas lui faire la blague de tirer sa chaise a elle pour qu'elle tombe..
Oh ce serait drôle ( Squeezie le sadique )
Tu sais un fantôme clown
( La meuf se fait victimiser par des chaises quand même )
Quoi ?!!!
Ah ouais... Fuis, fuis, part en coura...
Attends non attends
Là par contre c'est un peu too much
Mais attends elle s'est évanouie carrément !
Et ça continue de voler partout dans la salle ?!
Après, ça peut être organisé, ça peut être un fake
Ils ont accès au caméras de surveillance, ils savent
Ils mettent en place un truc
Ah c'est horrible !!
Bon, j'avoue la dernière m'a mis mal, je propose qu'on arrête maintenant
*voix bizarre* : Abonnez-vous
AH il m'a possédé !!!
Non franchement j'en rigole, mais... J'me chie dessus, j'me pisse dessus
J'aurais jamais le courage d'aller faire des explorations comme "Mamytwink" fait, ou comme même "Le Grand JD" a fait
Lui il est carrément aller sur l'Ile de Poveglia !!
J'ai envie d'y croire...
Mais dès y'a tout qui me montre qu'il faut y croire
Je n'y crois quand même pas ( c'est con )
Et j'pense qu'on est tous dans ce cas là, c'est terrible
Bref j'éspère que vous vous êtes bien bien pissé dessus
Hein, au final est-ce qu'on a pas plus peur à la fin de cette vidéo qu'a la fin d'un jeu d'horreur ?
SI !!!
Bon n'hésitez pas a aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu
Ca m'a fait super plaisir de faire cette vidéo, ça fait super longtemps que je voulais la faire
Mais j'avais jamais pris mes couilles pour les poser comme ça sur la table
*Tac*
Ah c'est le bruit qu'elles font quand je les pose parce qu'elles sont très très lourdes
ENORME !!
Je vous dis a tous merci d'avoir regardé, portez-vous bien...
Ciao tout le monde...
Peace !
(N'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo, à la partager et à mettre des commentaires sympathiques !)
(Bisous bisous <3)